news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
the experiment of sending kids back to
school during a raging hundred-year
pandemic
by this administration has failed
and uh it has failed very poorly and i'm
not pleased to see this and to be clear
i wish it were possible to send kids
back to school safely right now i it's
become very popular
among some on the right to say the left
wants to hurt businesses the left wants
to hurt education
the left wants uh luff doesn't care
about people's emotional health all
because they want to close close close
in order to hurt donald trump
i don't deny for a second that there are
tangible benefits
intangible benefits and psychological
benefits to getting kids back to school
i don't deny that many parents can't get
back to work unless their kids are back
in school
so i get it the considerations are
economic they're emotional they're
wide-ranging
when you have fifty thousand cases a day
fourteen hundred deaths a day
and we've already debunked the false
notion that kids can't catch the disease
or spread the disease
it just doesn't pass the sniff test that
this would work and case in point a
georgia second grader
tested positive on day one back in
school by day two
the classroom was closed the teacher and
students were quarantined for two weeks
and out of school
and there are many of these examples 260
employees
either tested positive or were exposed
in gwinnett county public schools in
georgia that's georgia's largest
school district hours after the first
day
in an indiana district last week the
county health department notified
greenfield central junior high that a
student who had been in a bunch of
classrooms all over the school
in contact with teachers and students
helped
was helping students i don't remember
the exact details was all over the
school
tested positive for coronavirus and once
again caused a mass
quarantine of 14 days for everybody that
they had been
in touch with we saw what happened in
israel
where they successfully dealt with the
virus crushed the curve i mean just
obliterated it obliterated the curve
opened schools and then things went
backwards
very very quickly so it's not
inconceivable
that states uh could open schools some
states could open schools safely
maybe but a lot has to happen in order
to do that
first and foremost when we were down to
20 000 cases a day
every state started opening that was not
the time to actually start
opening as aggressively as happened
number two
uh i know that it's august but we still
don't have enough testing
or fast enough testing the testing is
falling behind the viral spread when we
talk about how much we test relative to
other countries
remember that at this point
circumstances are so different in
countries
that in order to keep up with our level
of spread
we need dramatically more testing and we
need dramatically faster testing people
are often not hearing
back for days five to seven days in some
cases
a travel blogger i know waited 20 days
for his test results got them the day
before he was going to a different state
this is the same issue we've been
talking about for a long time when it
comes to lots of types of businesses and
organizations and
certainly schools where people are even
more crowded together
for hours all day there's not an easy
easy answer i
i'm not pretending this is simple i get
all of the reasons why we would want to
open schools
but what we've seen so far we have to be
guided by the data
tells me the risks exceed the possible
rewards
by the spring semester early 2021 we
might have both
more effective treatments and vaccines
that are increasingly inoculating people
so to me that says let's do online in
the fall i'm not saying don't do it i'm
saying let's do it online
let's suffer through it my mom is a
college professor up until two days ago
they were planning on allowing
professors to teach in person if they
wanted to now my mom had already decided
to go fully remote
but because of what's happening now in
massachusetts which by the way is
nothing compared to what's going on in
some states
her university decided we're doing all
remote it sucks
but it makes sense it's a mess it's not
political masks should be worn it's not
political
it's too early to open a lot of things
it's not political
i'm so glad i'm not in a position of
having to
send kids to school or not and make
decisions about where they should be
i don't envy the parents i don't envy
the teachers or the administrators i'm
not pretending it's easy i get it
there's not a simple answer
but it's increasingly clear that the
safe answer is
you've got to do online in the fall and
increasingly it seems more and more
states are going in that direction let
me know what's happening in your state
let me know on twitter at deepakman and
remember
you can listen to the david pakman show
podcast every day
every weekday okay we take weekends off
on whatever
your favorite podcasting app is spotify
itunes stitcher pandora it's quite a
laundry list it's almost
too easy to get the audio podcast but i
encourage you to do it